how do i gain more confidence it starts
with yourself man you got to start
diving into those things that you are
afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to a
spot that makes you feel good it's going
to be a false reality
and the second life gives you that
challenge
all you want to do is go back to or what
gave you confidence is that happy spot
no what gave me confidence was spending
years at a kitchen table
trying to learn how to read and write on
my own
realizing i can't learn the way you
learn i can't but i can learn what gives
you confidence not being afraid it's
overcoming the fear isis stutters
severely bad so right now i don't know
how many people are going to watch this
you know what gives me confidence
there's no i no longer care if i sit or
start stuttering to you that's what
gives me confidence is facing these
things overcoming them and maybe not
overcoming them every day
but facing them and facing their face
and preaching like this you know what
man this is the right thing it's not in
that comfort zone it's in the discomfort
zone is where my confidence is getting
built
that's where it's getting built but
people they want an easier answer there
has to be an easier way it's not i'm
sorry i searched for it my entire life
hey it's kevin carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one that's holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to have confidence
rule number two hold your ego in check
with ed mylett i want to start out
today's show by just reminding you of
something about you
because maybe no one's told you in a
little while you were born to do
something great with your life you're
supposed to do something special and
you're gonna i can promise you that you
have all the potential in the world
within you and i know the rest of the
world is probably telling you constantly
to be average to be ordinary you know
there's different haters you have in
your life there's people who put you in
your box there's people who overlook you
that make you feel invisible
and it's important that you hear from me
that that's not who you are
and by the way you're not even who
you've already been in your life your
past is not equal your future your
present does not equal your future and i
just want to remind you officially that
you can do something great with your
life and that you're destined to do
something great with your life and that
you were born for a reason so important
that you know that that you hear that
for me today and that you begin to
believe it about yourself because if you
don't believe that about yourself
there's no chance it's going to happen
you can't achieve something in your life
that you don't believe strongly
certainly that you can achieve and i
know that i find many of you today some
of you are listening to this today
you've got momentum in your life and
things are going well and you're looking
for a key or you want to hear about a
mistake you might make that you can miss
because i warn you about it
and i'm going to give you all those
things you know that on every program
but i know there's many of you that
arrive here today you're just not in the
in the groove
things aren't going great maybe you're
in a down cycle in your life maybe
there's some letdowns and some hurts
that are happening right now and maybe a
little bit of um you know a little
melancholy little anxiety a little fear
maybe all the way to some depression and
i just want to be that person who
reminds you that you can do something
special and that you're going to and you
have everything you need within you
right now to make your life great and
you can turn it around at any time you
decide to
you know what you allow is what's going
to continue in your life i put out a
post about this several weeks ago
it's hard to accept this but what's
happening in our lives we're allowing it
to happen and to some extent we almost
believe we deserve it because we produce
in our life what we really believe we're
worth what we really believe we deserve
and it doesn't it's hard to accept that
because it seems coincidental you know
that the wrong person entered a life or
there was a business setback or our car
broke down or you know our company went
out of business or whatever it might be
one of your clients just quit and change
their mind and it seems coincidental but
you really truly are getting out of your
life when you believe you're worth what
you believe you deserve and you're
allowing it to happen and i'm going to
challenge you today to stop that stop
allowing it and know that you deserve
better and so we're going to talk about
something very ironic today that doesn't
seem connected to it but it's absolutely
connected to it and that's ego
see the truth is ego is always false ego
is always something that raises its head
when we're insecure when we're fearful
if you meet people that you think are
egomaniacs that are consciously bragging
about themselves these are the most
insecure people that you know they're
the most fearful people that you know
they're the most scared and they're
usually the least happy and so but i'm
gonna say something to you i want you to
consider as i go through ego today i
know you think wow i'm so down on myself
how could i have an ego it's actually
the people that are down on themselves
that actually have their ego materialize
and show up more often than they think
and it's their ego that may actually be
holding them back you think wow how
could someone with low self-esteem have
a big ego well trust me they do and so
egos are not part of people with high
self-esteem the people in my life that
are the most self-confident
typically don't have big egos and so i
want to talk to you about the thing by
the way i'm covering this today like
many things i cover because it's
something i struggle with my ego will
step forward often in my life and it
usually steps forward when i'm the most
scared it could be when i'm achieving
i'm starting to be pretty full of myself
right but a lot of times when you're
achieving and you're full of yourself
what's really happening in your mind is
you're afraid you're going to fall down
you're afraid you're going to lose
something you're afraid there's going to
be a setback so often our friends where
we see their ego is when they're doing
good or she's she thinks she looks so
good she's showing herself actually
she doesn't think she looks good and
she's looking for validation from other
people you guys that have a friend who's
really winning he's making a lot of
money he's just not the same he's got a
big ego all of a sudden you'd be
surprised that money he's making that
car he's driving now he's so afraid he's
gonna lose it he's so scared he so
believes his results have exceeded who
he really is he's so out over his skis
that that ego shows up because he's
afraid when you see ego know it usually
means fear and i know that sounds
counterintuitive but it's true so we're
going to talk about just recognizing our
ego when it shows up because for me
either someone else points it out to me
close to me
or i see it in myself if you have to
wait around for other people to tell you
hey your ego's out of control
it's too late usually so we've got to be
able to see our ego when it rears its
head be aware of it and it loses its
power over us we can go back to being
our real selves which is point one today
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself and when our ego shows up
in a minute i'm gonna show you some not
so subtle ways egos show up and you're
going to see what i mean about maybe
your ego is present but remember this
when ego shows up we're not ourselves
we're not connected to god in other
words if you can let go of your ego you
can let god in when you can let go of
your ego you can let your real
confidence in when you let go of your
ego you can go really become who you
were born to be and so often times this
is so
important you get
you may be losing right now because of
your ego
because of your ego because you're not
feeling good about yourself wouldn't the
ultimate version of you not brag not
boast not tell stories about the past
not worry about what other people
thought about you right take criticism
very well all the things that we've
discussed today the ultimate version of
you would have none of those things
wouldn't he or she and that would be the
removal of your ego i believe the way we
remove our ego is we love ourselves
and we believe in ourselves and that way
we know ourselves and so what i want to
challenge you today is just to start to
give yourself a little bit more credit
and just know when you see these
symptoms arising in your life these are
indications your ego's out of control
and check yourself when it happens if
you have people in your life who embody
these symptoms it's often easy to see
the ego things that really repel us in
our life but the fact of the matter is
for me every single time in my life when
my ego gets the better of me i have a
setback
so listen to me it's very dangerous to
lead with your ego because i'm telling
you you're getting ready for a setback
in your life where my setbacks come from
in my life i'm going to tell you where i
have setbacks people ask me how do i get
out of my slump how do i break the habit
that i'm in and i'm going to tell you
what it is for me because it's connected
to ego for me i started to think i had
it so figured out when things were going
good that i stopped working on myself i
stopped reading the books i stopped
listening to the podcast i stopped
improving myself and when you do that
stuff the poor result doesn't show up as
you're doing it the poor result shows up
90 to 120 days later so that's the
problem the failure or the setback is
delayed by like 90 to 120 days in
everything we do so in business if
you're really successful right now and
you got to a certain point but you
stopped the very activities that got you
there
you don't fail the next day
90 to 120 days from now you pay the
price in your life don't you you didn't
do the work you were supposed to do and
so three four months later all of a
sudden business is down again so the
negative result always trails the
negative behavior by about three to four
months for me my happiness level or my
confidence level i always i got it going
and then i stop reading books i stopped
listening the right stuff i stopped the
right associations it didn't happen
immediately but 920 days later now my
ego is out of control again and so where
my ego rears its head for me is i begin
to think i got it figured out i think it
got it going i believe my own press
clippings and i stopped doing the things
that are going to get me to the next
level and three to four months later i
go man i'm in a slump man there's a
setback right now what the heck happened
what happened dummy ed mylett is 90 to
120 days ago you stopped doing the
things required to win
and so the truth is where you are right
now i love you brother or sister i want
you to win i opened up today by telling
you you're supposed to do something
great with your life but in order for
that to happen you have to do the great
things now because the positive results
will trail by six months to a year
so negatives come get us 90 to 120 days
but positives don't end up showing up
sometimes for six months to a year or
longer it's kind of like when you first
start to eat well you might get a little
bit improvement then it levels off and
you're like man i'm eating while i'm
working out why isn't my body changing
because the positive result is six
months to a year away
that's why but if you stop eating well
if you stop working out you're 60 to 90
120 days your body's bad again same with
our lives if we're doing something great
with our life it's gonna take us
six months to a year to see the positive
result and so don't let your ego get in
the way of saying man i'm doing all this
stuff and it's not working there's a
delayed gratification coming the same
time if you are winning right now don't
stop doing the things that got you where
you are because you're only 90 to 120
days away from a setback this is how the
ego gets us and so i want to remind you
in conclusion you're supposed to do
something great with your life you're
supposed to contribute you're supposed
to win but that starts with today loving
yourself which is believing in yourself
okay you can't be yourself if you don't
love yourself and you can't love
yourself if you don't believe in
yourself and so today start to love
yourself again i'm not about self love
that's not what i'm talking about you
know some thought i love me i love me
you know stuart smalley i'm good enough
i'm smart enough gosh darn it people
like me that's gonna get you nowhere do
things that are in congruence with who
you really are do things that are the
removal of your ego you know it says you
have no ego you're willing to do the
work every single day on yourself and in
your business even though there's no
result that shows no ego ego is why
would i keep doing it there's no result
or ego is i got it going i don't need to
do it anymore you want to know you don't
have an ego you want to know you got
your act together you're doing the work
right now to show how much you love
yourself how much you believe in
yourself knowing the delayed
gratifications coming six months to a
year or maybe longer from now i'm here
to challenge you to start living like
you love yourself living like you
believe in yourself because you can't
love yourself if you're not being
yourself and the real self the real you
takes all the steps to care for you all
the steps to improve you all the steps
to grow you so you know you love you you
know you believe in you when you begin
treating you like that rule number three
practice self acceptance with brendan
burchard you're always hearing about
this concept in personal development and
spiritual development of acceptance you
know the need that we must accept our
lives we must accept the difficulties of
our life we must accept and honor the
struggles that we face and we must
accept a lot of things that we don't
even like or approve of but how the hell
do you do that you know have you ever
heard someone says well it's time for
you to accept something and you get
upset at them because you don't like the
thing that you're struggling with then
how do you tell somebody to accept them
accept something from their past when it
was difficult somebody was mean to them
abuse them treated them bad the bad
incident happened you lost somebody that
you loved i mean it can be pretty
flippant when someone says well just
practice some self-acceptance dude
except
you and i both know that they are
usually right
you know is there something that you
know you've had to deal with in your
past but you haven't dealt with it is
there something going on right now
that's troubling you and it's causing so
much stress and overwhelm but it doesn't
go away it's always going to be there
well then this might be a good time to
think about this power of
self-acceptance and this extraordinary
ability we have in our mind and in our
heart
to deal with things that life is dealt
to us
and so let's talk about that a little
bit because i know it's hard to hear
this but i also think this might be your
next breakthrough when i work with a lot
of executives or a lot of high-flying
people who are just extraordinarily
capable and confident but they're always
stressed they're always upset
acceptance is one of their ways out when
people you know are trying to become
more mindful and and thoughtful and
present in the world try that without
more self-acceptance you just sit there
and get upset right so
there's a couple of tools a couple of
simple things to think about number one
is just defining self-acceptance for you
as a power it's time to develop that
it's a weaponry in life when you can
accept things
you're stronger than others like if
somebody's sitting there and they're
screaming at you and
being mean and being rude when you take
it personally
and you're not accepting the reality of
the situation and all you want to do is
fight and fight and argue and argue
that's where people get in relationships
where they're fighting over and over and
over and over again because they can't
accept that maybe that person that's
their reality sometimes you have to
accept other people's position in life
without trying to change them as much as
you have to accept yourself without
trying to change yourself as much as you
have to accept the past without having
to try to change the past so let's talk
maybe a little about how you could do
that what's what's the process for that
the first thing is defining
self-acceptance for you not
as approval right of course you don't
approve the person screaming at you of
course you don't approve the bad
situation that happened in the past or
the bad medical report of course you
don't accept the fact that sometimes
life isn't what you want so stop
thinking it's about approval acceptance
isn't about approval
acceptance
is about peace
it's learning to be at peace with what
is even if you don't like it
and especially if you can't change it
i'll give you an example uh some of you
all know i lost my father in 2009 to
acute myeloid leukemia when he got that
diagnosis
it really tore through our family
because you know
my dad and all we were just all so close
and we loved him so much
and it was a
you know a diagnosis that he was going
to pass away very soon from his
diagnosis to his death was only 59 some
days
and so
it was hard to accept that that was
what was going to happen that we were
going to lose someone we love because
especially he hadn't been sick all of a
sudden he just got sick and they found
well leukemia is taking your body out of
nowhere and then he was gone
and we had to
accept that that was
part of the process it doesn't mean that
he didn't fight and we didn't try to
find everything we could do for him you
know in that amount of time
he did he fought the good fight he went
through three different treatments of
chemo he tried everything tried
everything and he's you know had been a
21-year
uh marine he'd been through it all he'd
been through vietnam in three different
tours he's been shot up he'd been he was
a strong guy and he fought but he also
was almost like that peaceful warrior
you know what i mean he was
at peace either way he was gonna do his
best
but he was gonna
accept the outcome that god or the
universe placed in his path at that time
of his life and it gave me strength
trying to be the son to cope with the
situation trying to be there to to see
someone going through struggle
and as much as they're struggling and
fighting it or honoring it to see them
accept the path
right to accept your hardships to go
okay this is the path that i have right
now god the universe whatever it put it
in front of me i'm gonna do my darndest
i'm gonna be here i'm gonna be present
i'm gonna engage it i'm not gonna run
i'm not gonna avoid it but i'm also not
gonna hate it
i'm not gonna add negative fuel to a
negative situation instead i'm going to
peacefully and persistently give my best
to deal with this at my best right now
i'm not going to hate the process be mad
at process i accept that this is the
challenge the universe has given me
right now let me see what i can do
and that's a much more positive mindset
than avoiding it because you know
avoidance is is a great short-term
strategy to avoid pain and discomfort
but avoidance is also a long-term
strategy to guarantee suffering right to
avoid dealing with what we have to in
life that's the opposite of acceptance
you know it's about engage with it
do your best don't hate the process
that's acceptance too right
i think another way to look at
acceptance is
through the lens of trust
trust that you are capable
trust that things will get better trust
that this too shall pass trust that
whatever is here not only has been put
here but it is something you can deal
with if you survive it
then there is a reason you learn
something you develop something you will
get better over time even if right now
it sucks even if it's been painful even
if you're sad about it and even though i
also had a brain injury in 2011
that was incredibly difficult left a
two-year
just swath of pain in my life you know i
it was very difficult
um time when i was trying to overcome a
brain injury trying to get back in the
game trying to build my business and my
career trying to write books do all
these things you see me do
it was bad timing too
i mean it was just all around bad
but all i could do is go okay i will
repair myself
it might take long but i'll repair
myself i trust
that if i focus if i stay persistent if
i keep trying i know that it will get
better over a period of time even if it
didn't change physically
i was going to free my mind by accepting
that this was where i was at still
working but accepting i hope that helps
and sometimes maybe the easiest way to
think about self-acceptance
is to think what would you tell your
friend
you know if you find yourself
fighting something in your life
if you had a friend who was going
through that exact same situation what
would you tell him
you'd probably say hey do your best
hey um trust hey have faith hey believe
wouldn't you say something like that
you if they kept fighting against it
over and over and over you'd want them
to have some peace about it and you try
to comfort them
so what about giving yourself some peace
what about comforting yourself
what about accepting the fact that you
know you've probably been doing your
best
what about accepting the fact that when
you screwed up you hurt somebody's
feeling you know you're in a better
place now you're older more mature more
capable now so maybe
another way to think about acceptance
isn't just trust but also
forgiveness
maybe it's time to forgive that time you
did that dumb thing
maybe it's time to forgive that time
you you just hated yourself for doing
something maybe it's time
to let go
i think of self-acceptance in those ways
i think of self-acceptance in
understanding that i can engage the
process without hating it in
understanding that i'm going to trust
this is here for a reason to pull the
best of me and i also really think of
acceptance as ultimately forgiveness of
the things that i did or others did so
that now in this moment i can be
free because that is the benefit of
acceptance whether you accept another
person you've been arguing with or upset
with and you finally accept that's the
way they are or that's how it's going to
be it's freeing because now you have to
carry along the anger and the upset
you're just like well that's the way it
is that's the way they are not bitter
not upset just at a peaceful level to
understand have empathy to give
compassion and go oh okay this is all
right i trust that this is all going
just like it's supposed to do i'll keep
doing my best but here we go i think if
you can have those lenses on
self-acceptance it becomes a power and
that power gives you freedom it gives
you that peace in the moment and gives
you the better choices for tomorrow and
when you have the better choices for
tomorrow you start to experience what we
call
the charge
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four be more confident
with vanessa van edwards here's the myth
i was told over and over again
confidence either have it or you don't
and no one quite knows how to get it if
you don't
this myth is pervasive and damaging it
destroys tiny fragile beautiful little
buds of confidence before they can grow
and i want your confidence to grow and
flourish and i know it can
confidence isn't something that arrives
at birth it's a skill one that can be
developed through intentional and
purposeful practice here's how
number one how to look confident
for this video i'm going to do something
a little different we're going to start
with the outside in when it comes to
confidence sometimes it's a faster route
let's start with your confident looks
and no i don't mean your clothes or your
hair this tip is all about your body
language let me ask you a question when
you walk into a networking event or
office or restaurant do you look like a
winner this may seem like a strange
question but research from the
university of british columbia makes it
clear we innately get bigger in our
bodies when we feel pride but get
smaller in our bodies when we feel
defeated or ashamed
why does this matter without realizing
it when we look at someone we're trying
to decide if they look more like a
winner or a loser is someone taking up
space do they have their head held high
and their shoulders down and relaxed or
do they look like a loser with their
shoulders rolled in their chin to their
chest and a slouched position
without realizing it we make snap
judgments of people the moment we see
them and then put them into one of two
buckets
in order to be confident your body
language must show it first the easiest
way to look like a winner is to claim
our territory own your body and own the
space around you by standing or sitting
tall keep your arms loose by your side
relax your shoulders down your back and
open your chest these expansive postures
will show others that you're confident
and sure of yourself
be wary of low power postures like
crossing your arms or turtling your
shoulders to your ears as this may
signal defeat
number two how to speak confidently
now that you've learned how to look
confident let's talk about how to sound
confident when you answer the phone and
when you start a new conversation it's
crucial that your voice projects
confidence but how we make our first
impression in our hello upon answering
the phone the question is is your voice
helping or hurting your confidence here
at science of people we did a
fascinating experiment on vocal power
and have some incredible tips for you on
how you can make your voice sound better
and how to benefit from every single
phone conversation
we asked participants to record
themselves saying hello in six different
ways
normal hello
happy hello
sad hello
angry hello
power posing hello
and
normal hello again
we added these recordings to our website
and asked our readers to tell us how
much they liked or didn't like the
person in the recording just based on
the hello they heard
readers listened to each clip and
selected one of the following answers i
like this person a lot i like this
person a little or i don't like this
person at all
which version of the hello do you think
was the most likable the winner was the
happy hello of course the data revealed
that the happy recordings received
significantly more approval ratings than
any other hello this is a huge finding
as it shows people can hear your mood
which variation do you think did the
worst the angry hello
action step your mood affects your voice
never ever answer the phone in a bad
mood and if you have an important call
watch some funny youtube videos to bring
some natural smiles into your face
number three does happiness equal
confidence
happiness and confidence go hand in hand
if you're curious about how to be more
confident at work one of the best ways
to feel professionally confident is to
have meaningfulness in your job do you
know your company's mission do you know
the impact of your work when we don't
know how our daily responsibilities
contribute to a larger mission we can
feel disengaged or hopeless in our
workplace
there is nothing worse than feeling like
what you do doesn't matter
here are some ideas to add meaning to
your day first find out your company's
mission statement or if it's your
company create a mission statement if
your company doesn't have one write the
mission statement you think your company
should have maybe you can even bring it
up to your bosses
second
write your own personal mission
statement why do you do what you do
beyond just a paycheck who are you
helping this could be your colleagues
your team or your clients put this
mission statement somewhere easy to see
on your desk or hang it on your cubicle
wall
lastly make a success folder on your
computer this is a folder that contains
records of accomplishments testimonials
and any other example of your rockstar
status at work if you're having a bad
day open your success folder to remind
yourself of your worth action step watch
all 10 ways to be happier at work to
boost your day-to-day satisfaction
number four how to walk confidently
did you know your walk can project your
confidence
biomotion lab analyzes and synthesizes
biological motion patterns a fancy way
of saying they study walking and
movement for patterns biological motion
looks at how emotions and intentions can
change our walk the human visual system
is highly sensitive to our motion and
without realizing it we're capable of
decoding things about people from their
walk we investigate the question of how
such information is encoded in
biological motion and how it can be
retrieved they apply linear methods from
statistics to patterns to recognition to
analysis
they use several variants to show
different kinds of walks from gender to
weight to nervousness to happiness see
the differences interesting right
action step how do you walk film
yourself walking and see if you can
slide more towards relaxed and happy see
how that changes how you feel
number five find a confident role model
confidence is easier to develop when we
can watch and emulate someone in action
do you have someone in your life who
exudes confidence professionally or
personally maybe a partner a colleague
or a close friend assign them as your
confidence role model this can be a
secret role model you observe and take
notes of how they interact or you can
talk to your role model and ask them to
be your mentor there's no better
compliment than telling someone their
natural confidence is alluring this can
lead to multiple benefits including you
bonding with them on a deeper level them
sharing ideas on how you can up your
individual confidence and maybe even
some insider tips on how they got to
their own confidence levels
not sure who to choose look for a role
model in the workplace who embodies the
following qualities
shows confidence in their leadership
isn't afraid to be unique
communicates interacts with everyone
shows respect and concern for everyone
they meet is knowledgeable and
well-rounded has humility and shows
willingness to admit mistakes does good
things outside the job what i love about
this list of qualities is that many are
unexpected confidence comes in multiple
flavors it isn't about being the most
extroverted bubbly person in the room
sometimes it's about empathy humility
competence
number six pump up your confidence
are you in a funk when we experience
burnout or exhaustion our confidence
tends to dip a fun option to ramp up
your confidence is by creating different
kinds of confidence playlists this can
be a spotify playlist that gets you in a
good mood or a youtube playlist that
inspires you listen or watch when you're
brushing your teeth getting ready or on
your commute anytime you need a pump up
want to listen to our free audio
training i would love to pump you up
learn how to stand out from your peers
with our praiseworthy performance free
audio training listen right now at
scienceofpeople.com
praiseworthy
number seven overcome imposter syndrome
for many high achievers success comes at
a price and this price is known as
imposter syndrome this is a
psychological phenomenon that causes
smart talented people to feel like a
fraud to feel undeserving of their
accomplishments
studies have found that 70 of all people
feel like imposters at one time or
another this is a huge problem here's
the most important thing to keep in mind
this is not a defect imposter syndrome
is not a personality trait it's a
reaction to an event do you ever think
your accomplishments are just not enough
or pure luck do you ever worry that
people will find out that you aren't
worthy
this is impostor syndrome at work and
it's temporary and overcomable when our
mind and thoughts work against us our
confidence shrivels up and hides away
one way to fight imposter syndrome is
with motivating self-talk stop feeling
like a fraud with this video
on a more serious note if you get
stressed out in social settings it's
possible you may be suffering from
social anxiety social anxiety is when
you feel nervous tense or uncomfortable
in social situations because you're
worried other people are judging you
almost everyone has experienced social
anxiety at one point or another life is
rife with moments of self-consciousness
from job interviews to first dates we
all occasionally feel nervous around
other people unfortunately social
anxiety can become at worst debilitating
and at the very least damper our inner
confidence and make it feel impossible
to be social in an authentic way the
good news is there are ways to overcome
your social anxiety with a treatment
known as cognitive behavioral therapy or
cbt i mention this here because if
you're having a more serious issue with
confidence i highly recommend getting
professional help cbt is recognized as
one of the most effective treatment
options for social anxiety think about
getting more help and learn more about
social anxiety and how to deal in our
full video
number eight how to spark confidence in
your brain
our thoughts dictate nearly every aspect
of our existence and if our thoughts are
insecure or demotivated it's nearly
impossible to think and feel confidently
about ourselves
chad helmstetter author of what to say
when you talk to yourself argues that we
are programmed by our thoughts our
mindset and our self truths are the
epicenter of our confidence
self truths the ideas we tell ourselves
the beliefs we carry around whether they
are true or not
what are the stories you tell yourself
what are your truths and are these
factual truths or assumed truths many
people tell themselves i'll never be
good at sports or i'm not creative
enough or i could never own my own
business
i want you to dig into these truths a
bit more do you believe this because
someone told you that you would never
succeed at fill in the blank is there a
deeper insecurity that contributes to
this limiting belief
go through three of your biggest
limiting beliefs and do some fact
checking where did they come from why
and do you want to keep them bouncing
around in your head take ownership of
the thoughts that only serve you
number nine limit social media
consumption
we all love a good dog photo on
instagram right well surmounting
research shows that social media is
hurting us the endless comparison we
subject ourselves to by this
technological vehicle can have lasting
and harmful effects researcher clarissa
silva interviewed men and women between
the ages of 28 and 73 and found these
crazy results
sixty percent of people using social
media reported that has impacted their
self-esteem in a negative way fifty
percent reported social media having
negative effects on their relationships
80 reported that it's easier to be
deceived by others through their sharing
on social media this insecurity is
especially rampant in the online dating
space according to silva it seems that
social media is creating a paradox
effect giving off the illusion of many
choices while making it harder to find
viable options the paradox effect in
dating is creating the illusion of
having more social engagement social
capital and popularity but masking one's
true persona remember there is a big
bright world happening around you social
media helps to stay connected and
informed but it's also important to find
a balance between reality and fantasy
want to conquer your social media for
every hour you spend on social media in
the next month spend the equivalent time
with friends or family in person to
balance it out here's the bottom line
the path to more confidence is in your
hands confidence doesn't grow without
water fertilizer and a little tlc take
steps even small ones to up your
confidence and kick start the life you
always wanted rule number five destroy
self-doubt with marie corleo if you ever
wrestle with self-doubt about i don't
know what you're writing what you're
creating i gotta tell you this is a must
watch episode now if you follow me on
instagram or you read my emails which
you should then you know i've been
working on my next book and as soon as i
started talking about it i got to tell
you i got all these questions people
started asking about my writing process
how soon is it going to be ready can you
tell me more about it so i want to start
with my writing process now
i don't really talk about it much
because to be honest it's a proprietary
formula in fact i've developed it over
years and i keep it under lock and key
just kidding i'll tell you exactly what
my writing process is so my writing
process is this intoxicating blend of
despair and struggle and agony and total
insecurity and overwhelm and panic with
some subtle top notes of self-loathing
ah yes this is just like my creative
process
i've had this before are you sure this
isn't my creative process
anyway so
recently i was working on my book in la
and i was in the midst of feeling all of
this angst about my writing i was
totally questioning my capabilities so i
got to work out and i was just leaving
gold's gym i got on my bike and i
started riding my bike home and this
woman was on the sidewalk and she was
running past me and then she looked back
and did a double take and she said are
are you marie forloo and i was like yes
i am marie forleo who are you
and she told me her name was rebecca she
says i have to tell you something i love
your book it changed my life she's like
no really i'm not just saying this i'm
not blowing smoke up your butt your book
totally transformed my life so i'm
standing there with my bike all sweaty
almost in tears and i'm like rebecca
well i have something to tell you you
have no idea how much what you just
shared means to me right now in this
moment i mean the whole reason i'm here
in la is i am working on my next book
and i'm just starting out and i'm
struggling with it each and every day so
to hear you tell me how much my first
book meant to you which is something i
never hear anymore you're like the most
beautiful sign from the universe telling
me to keep going so thank you so here's
me and my new friend becky very sweaty
and happy on the street in venice and if
you're not familiar with miss becky
lynch turns out she is a
wwe superstar and the inaugural
smackdown women's champion
[Applause]
i gotta say becky you are inspiring me
to give my writing self-doubt the
smackdown all my whiny little complaints
i want to just
put them in the death grip so thank you
thank you thank you becky and two
important things i want you to take away
from this experience my little story
about becky so number one if someone's
work means something to you do not be
shy about saying something i mean really
i can't tell you how unbelievably
grateful i was that becky did that
double take on the street and she said
hey hey are you marie her words gave me
so much life in the exact moment that i
needed them now even if you don't run
into folks on the street don't
underestimate the power of just saying
something whether you write them an
email or you send a little handwritten
note or a card whatever you know most of
us don't realize how much people that we
might consider to be creative superstars
those people struggle with the same
exact fears and doubts and insecurities
that we have and you just never know
when your words can help someone else
really change their day or their week or
their entire life
and number two this is really important
if you're feeling insecure about what
you have to share whether it's your
message or your writing or your product
or your service and you're debating
about whether or not you should put it
out there you need to remember i know i
say this every week but you got to hear
it the world really does need that
special gift that only you have it needs
your ideas and your message and your
story because what you have to offer
could really change someone else's life
and that person needs to hear it from
you and guess what they might only be
able to hear it from you you just don't
know the pain or the struggle that
somebody else might be battling with
that you could help with
you never know if just by being brave
enough to speak up and share what you do
and who you are the impact that you can
have on another human being's life now i
gotta say if writing is one of the ways
that you hope to help people but maybe
you're feeling a little stuck or a
little unsure of how to express your
unique voice you have got to get your
butt over to the copycure.com
right the second now yes we do have this
full-on writing course and you can sign
up for that if you want but honestly the
sample class and the email series that
you get for free it is so
damn good frankly i think everybody on a
planet should just go sign up for the
free stuff and i promise you the tips
that you'll learn and everything that
you'll get from that free series will
help you become a stronger more
confident writer starting right now
and if you ever ever doubt the
difference that you can make to others
just by being brave and sharing what's
in your heart i want you to remember
this tweetable
one kind word can change someone's day a
few kind words can change their whole
life rule number six become unstoppable
with john ashraf here's a question for
you have you ever thought to yourself
that you're not smart enough or that
you're not good enough or that you don't
have the knowledge or the skills to
achieve your biggest goals and dreams i
can share with you that i used to have
those exact thoughts and beliefs about
myself
now in this video i'm going to share
with you how you can start to have
unstoppable confidence and certainty in
yourself so you can become a powerhouse
a person who can not just set goals but
achieve whatever goals you choose in
your life
now many years ago when i was on the
ellen degeneres show i was in the green
room with minnie driver and minnie
driver is a hollywood celebrity who
everybody knows around the world if you
watch a little bit of television and i
asked minnie a question
i asked her how is it that you can take
a script that your agent gives you and
how do you become
the role so that you can either win an
academy award or an oscar or any of the
awards that they give actors and
actresses and she said to me she said
john nobody's really ever asked me that
question and so let me share with you
what she told me that i think will help
you understand what it's going to take
for you to not just set goals but for
you to achieve your goals
she said to me that once she gets the
script she reads it three four five
times to see if it's really what she
wants to trade her life for
then she says when she accepts the
script and the contract that her agent
obviously connects her with the studios
with
she then goes by a process of practice
drill and rehearse and what does that
mean
well what it means is she takes hours
every single day to practice her role in
the script she does research on the role
and then once she thinks then feels that
she has the role really well felt in her
emotional self
she then moves that to the camera
now why does that process work well the
reason the process works is because when
we
have a goal that we look at once or
twice or three times our brains really
forget what the goals are unless we get
it to go from the conscious aware part
of our personality and our psyche and
into the unconscious
implicit part of our brain and psyche
through rehearsal through practiced
repetition through practice drilling and
rehearsing every single day
what you do is you set up a new neural
pathway in your brain a new pattern for
your brain to not only emotionalize but
a new pattern for your brain to have you
think about a new pattern for your brain
to have you look for a new pattern for
your brain to get your physical body to
move into action towards
and so if you want to achieve your goals
and dreams
write out your script and then every
single day what i want you to do is read
the script
visualize and see yourself already being
in the role having achieved what you
want to achieve instead of just having
the goal
written on a piece of paper
what i want you to also do is i want you
to practice being that role
if your role is about being healthier
then i want you to visualize it i want
you to read it i want you to look at
whatever you've written or whatever you
have cut out in a magazine or from any
other source to be able to create a
collage
of that goal or that dream that you have
for yourself and then every day i want
you to take action towards that and
practice that role until
you and the goal and the dream become
one you have to go from the i want part
to the i am part and the more you can
bridge the gap between what you want and
who you are the more you'll be able to
create an academy award-winning
performance in your own life the more
you integrate your vision with your
emotions
with your actions the more you will
become
the role the more you will become the
person who sets goals and achieves goals
if you do what most people do you'll set
goals and never really emotionalize them
you'll set goals and never really take
actions consistently towards them but if
you thought about becoming a hollywood
actor or actress and you were going to
be paid a million or 5 million or 10
million dollars to be that role
guess what you would do you'd practice
you drill and you'd rehearse in private
and in public so that you and your goal
become one
and that's when you start to act and
think and feel every single day the way
you need to act and think and feel until
you achieve your goals and dreams rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is eliminate
things that hold you back with dean
graziosi today i want to talk about
confidence i could talk about confidence
literally once a week because it's so
important to your next level of success
if you're watching this video excuse me
i just left the gym i'm sweaty i'm i'm
freaking my face is red didn't shave
today but i don't care i got a message i
literally was running on the stairmaster
walking on the stairmaster sweating
thinking about you guys and thinking
about the impact of confidence in your
life i just did an event this weekend in
san diego it was amazing group of people
and i went deep on confidence i watched
people get it you see if you are
listening to this podcast you're
listening to other podcasts that
motivate you give you capabilities to go
faster quicker make more money have more
freedom control in your life all those
types of things but none of it listen to
me listen to this clearly maybe for the
first time in your life really hear me
none of it is possible if your
confidence is down
so i want you to think about the things
in your life
that steal your confidence and remember
when i say steal your confidence i don't
mean that you have a hundred percent of
confidence and you do something and you
go to twenty percent or ten percent i'm
talking about when your confidence is
off just five percent do you make smart
decisions when your confidence is down
do you go after the business do you ask
for the money do you start the the
website do you do you uh get the girl do
you get the promotion do you ask your
boss for a raise no your confidence is
down you that's when you start saying
well maybe this is good enough maybe my
relationship is good enough i should
just be happy with what i got i should
just be happy with the money i make
screw that
if you were happy you wouldn't be here
you'd be doing something else right now
besides listening or watching me so
let's just face the facts where you are
right now is not sufficient for you
doesn't mean it's horrible but it's not
enough
and if you want to get to that next
level you need to protect your
confidence
by any shape measure or form protect it
so what are the things that dig your
confidence i realized
at an early early time it's probably
been 10 years
that watching the news for me when i
watch the news and i see that it looks
like the world is going to hell in a
hand basket or what the president is
saying today or what congress is saying
or you listen to the left or the right
or or people in the middle if you listen
to all the gun violence and all like all
the news does for me is make me question
where the world is going in my next
level so for 10 years now i've been on a
news diet i don't watch the news i have
no clue what's going on nor do i care it
was the biggest transformation in my
life
i where i want to spend my time i want
to spend time with my family the people
i love my kids my team members they
deserve the best of me they don't
deserve dean at 95 confidence they
deserve a hundred percent and if i watch
the news it it brings it down so i won't
be the best team leader i won't be the
best father i won't be the best man i
can be i won't be the best uh
inspiration for you so screw the news it
dings my confidence it's out i've been
on a news diet i challenge you to do the
same thing for me i don't know about you
but if if you have your phone i'm
recording on my phone here i'm stopped
now i can talk to you um but i don't
know this is my wallet but if you ever
look at your phone if it dings someone
texts you or calls you and you look at
you go oh should i answer this now
should i answer it later to me that robs
my confidence i don't want those people
in my life i either have to set
boundaries
or have to push them out of my life
listen let's just be honest stop feeling
bad for other people stop dimming your
glow stop talking about your
aspirational next level stop fantasizing
about your dreams in front of people
because it may insult them or make them
feel inferior or they may tell you
you're a dreamer if that's the case push
them out of your life or become teflon
and don't listen to their
and in plain speaking if you if someone
gives you advice if you wouldn't replace
your life with theirs they give you
advice on how to make money how to fix
your relationship how to get a promotion
but most of the time people are
unqualified giving us advice the broke
friend telling us how to make money
the unhappy miserable single friend
telling us how to fix our marriage
bad advice is the most costly advice in
the world but i take it one step deeper
you've heard that before but bad advice
to me dings my confidence it's got to go
so if if bad advice dings your
confidence then get to push the people
out that are bringing you down and
making you dim your glow push them out
of your life or if they're really close
in your life find a way to not let their
words affect you unless you'd rather be
them
another thing that dings your confidence
in a massive way
is working on your weaknesses the
biggest lie we've ever been told in the
history of the world or one of them is
that we should get strong or weak at the
hell would that
get amazing at what you're good at
because when you work on the things
you're good at the things that make you
thrive and feel alive your confidence
goes up when your confidence goes up
then everything else starts to get
easier you don't look at things as a
problem you look at things as a
challenge when you walk into the meeting
to ask for the promotion ask for the
raise ask for the partnership you don't
go oh my god will this work maybe i
should be happy to go no i got this i
got this your chest puffs up your
physiology changes your breathing
changes the way you look on your face
changes do you ever take a picture when
you're stressed and your confidence is
low it's like huh yeah hi and then all
of a sudden you look at another picture
like wow i looked amazing in that
picture why did i look so good because
your confidence was up so right now this
is your call to action and by the way if
you haven't yet go to subscribe to
dean.com subscribe to dean.com so you
can follow me get notifications get free
free bonuses get discounts all kinds of
cool stuff and that's why these podcasts
are growing so fast because of all of
you registering but this week what i
want you to do is i would like you to
start making a list yeah i'm giving you
an assignment don't stop just listening
to podcasts and start doing listen i
i've failed miserably in my life but
i've had massive success
i'm sharing this with you today so you
can avoid the potholes so you can avoid
void the pitfalls so you can go faster
to your next level why go through your
own trial and error when i've been here
so do this exercise don't just think
about it don't just be inspired do it
this week start writing down everything
in your life that makes you feel a
little bit less than confident
someone in your life a relationship
watching the news working on your
weaknesses
redundant work negative people whatever
it is start recognizing it and start
eliminating those things in your life
start figuring out how you could push
them out or become teflon or switch it
or adjust it or go on a one week news
night just go this week without watching
one bit of news and use that time that
you'd watch the news or surf online
looking at stupid crap that doesn't do
anything for your life use that time
working on you
read a book
read powerful by peggy mccall read shoe
dog by phil knight read
principles by ray daly read something
that takes you forward and eliminate the
crap that holds you back
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do
something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up
and you find a reason why you can't do
it
it's too hard too difficult it's too
scary
most people will let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah
that's way too hard i mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
i could have done it
you know like that's the worst feeling
in the world that you could have done
something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why
you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals
they're not tough either
and we're reinforcing that comfort loop
every day
comfort you versus growth you are in a
fight
there's a war going on inside you
comfort you versus growth you comfort
evan birth is growth heaven every day
there's a fight there's a battle there's
a war going on and you need to decide
who's gonna win
the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you
wins against comfort you the more you
start to grow the more you start to hit
your goals the more you start to have an
impact the more you start to love
yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world will let
you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
i think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not i
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up two major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift
400 pounds you start by lifting 5 pounds
or 10 pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are
much more than the one-off heroic
moments
here's an example so uh yesterday we had
an insane snowstorm here in toronto i
don't know if we can that's kind of
blurry can't see we had like you see
something here behind me it's like look
and see that mountain of snow behind me
we had an insane snowstorm we had
probably the worst snowstorm
in toronto canada in a decade i have not
seen this much snow in a crazy amount of
time and so i'm going for a walk
uh rocking and rocking is where you
carry a backpack so i'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as i'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside
normally the rocking alone is hard
enough and i just increased the weight
in the backpack now there's no path to
walk on
and this morning i was walking through
an area and there was zero path the snow
is up to my knees and i need to get
through
so what's what are my options well i
could i could complain and turn around
right like i could look out the window
and say ah so much snow i'm not going to
do that
i'll do it when there's less snow you
know and then the next day there's less
snow there's still snow and the mexico
snow and then all of a sudden you just
give up on the habit right like you let
yourself off the hook to say i'll do it
tomorrow and then and then you never do
it and then the habit's gone and that's
what you're teaching yourself this is
why it leads to identity this is why it
leads to negative self-worth and
negative self-confidence because the
next time you come up with an idea
you've already reinforced the training
you're training yourself that when you
come up with an idea you don't do the
thing
when you say you're going to do it and
you're going to start tomorrow and then
you don't the next time you come up with
an idea guess what
you've already reinforced the pattern i
don't follow through i'm not going to do
that i'm excited today but tomorrow i
won't follow through
so there's a snow it's up to my knees
right up to my knees and i'm 6'1 so it's
it's some serious snow like i gotta walk
through not quite that that's that's
probably taller than me i don't have to
walk through that much but but up to my
knees
i'm looking at it and i've got to go
i don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was man why is
there no path why has nobody shoveled
this why is nobody still blow this like
gotta get over there i got a backpack on
i'm rocking i'm sweating like crazy i'm
already exhausted now i gotta go through
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right
everybody would have let me off the hook
and an another me would have let me off
the hook right comfort evan would have
let growth happen off the hook so it's
okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through
that
snow up to your knees
and as soon as i caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you look outside and
see the snow and not go
just by default not even catching the
the conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment
what do you do do you do the difficult
thing or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice
this is how we start to either change
our identity or reinforce our identity
so i looked at it i caught it and said
i'm going through let's go
you know i caught the negative thinking
i caught the comfort evan coming over
walk around go home nope not happening
we're going through we are going through
we are going to make it through
and it was rough
yeah i'm walking through i'm freezing uh
i'm taking one kind of giant step at a
time snow is getting all through my
boots all down my legs i i almost slip
and fall i have a coffee that i that i
picked up uh it's dripping all over the
place
and in my head as i'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go evan you got this man
let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that i'm also telling
myself that you know what not only am i
doing this difficult thing for me
i'm also creating the path for other
people that the next person who comes up
against this 100 meters or so
that now they will have not an easy time
but an easier time of crossing the same
path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two
default the service that it's not just
about you it's for other people now that
may not even be true
maybe nobody ever comes
across that path maybe i didn't make it
easier for the next person maybe
somebody comes five minutes after me and
snow blows the whole thing and so there
was zero service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
i'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that i use one is
language so scary difficult or hard
if you say those things if you feel
those things if you text those things if
you write those things if you're talking
yourself when you catch those things
then you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself saying
speaking right and thinking scary
difficult to heart that's a that's a
trigger it should be a trigger it's a
trigger for me it should be a trigger
for you to go and do it do it go walk
through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and i'm gonna be cold and have snow on
my boots how does that help me it's an
identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow
matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly like
when your heart is going crazy like that
it's usually because
you should be doing something you're
afraid
right now don't again go don't go
don't go standing on the highway
uh because it's scary and it makes your
heart race right don't be stupid but
most of the things that you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not
they're usually it's other people's
opinions usually you're afraid of not
failing but somebody watching you fail
right you're going to fail at something
who's going gonna see you that's what
we're actually afraid of and that cannot
be a good enough reason it can't not
anymore if you're afraid of losing in
front of somebody if you're afraid of
other people's opinions if you are
living your life based off of the
expectations and judgment of the people
you will never do anything great you
will never live your great life because
somebody always has a plan for what you
should be doing with your life you will
never please everybody it's not possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong i'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason they do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to
do and so learning to do difficult
things
teaching yourself step by step grip by
brick one snow
storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
and that comes
on the other side of you doing the
things that are scary difficult
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to have a purposeful life with
confidence check the video right there
next to us i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and we'll see you
there in today's environment you need to
be flexible you need to listen um
and be able to pivot and change really
fast belief innovation and
resourcefulness will take you everywhere
okay this is going to show my brilliance
evan you ready for a deep